prince harry and meghan markle are
paying tribute to prince philip
in a special way megan was really keen
to be
here with prince harry to support him
on saturday the royal family came
together to honor the life of the duke
of edinburgh
at st george's chapel at windsor castle
notably missing from the intimate
ceremony was prince harry's wife meghan
markle
but her tribute to the late prince did
not go unnoticed
providing this wreath
the duke and duchess of sussex
specifically chose a few sentimental
pieces like the national flower of
greece
to represent prince philip's heritage
and see holly to represent the royal
marines
well prince harry was incredibly close
to prince philip they
shared they shared a bond over the
military
the wreath also features rosemary to
signify remembrance
lavender for devotion and campanula to
signify gratitude and everlasting love
along with the wreath followed a
handwritten note by the duchess of
sussex
e.t has learned that megan watched the
service from home in california
her doctors would not clear her for
international travel
at this stage of her pregnancy megan and
harry are expecting baby number two
a girl later this year well of course
leaving behind his heavily
pregnant wife it isn't what he wanted to
do
um my understanding is that megan was
really keen to be
here with prince harry to support him
through what is
clearly a very very difficult and and
personal time for him
but she is now in the late stages of her
pregnancy she's well into her third
trimester
she's 39 as well and you know that that
comes with certain risks attached to it
and
she doesn't want to take any risks and
for that reason and on the advice of her
position she was told
to stay behind so i think it of course
it's a difficult journey for prince
harry to make on his own
and she would have loved to have been
there to support him but they are
putting
her health the health of their unborn
baby first
and prince harry has come over to the uk
alone
we are here today in saint george's
chapel
to commit into the hands of god the soul
of his servant prince philip duke of
edinburgh
adding to the meaning of the day the
family held prince philip's funeral at
the very same
chapel where harry and megan tied the
knot in 2018.
but that really highlights the
importance of the venue so george's
chapel is a royal
family chapel and so many moments have
happened there
there are monarchs from the past buried
at that chapel
there are many great memories from
family christenings
and also weddings of the past so it's a
place where family history runs deep and
ultimately
on the day of prince philip's funeral it
will be a celebration of just that
a family
[Music]